der doktor assmann an sie als erstes
dank den hausärzten konnten wir ja
gleich zwei im rekorde diese woche
verzeichnen
dürfen wir uns über diesen trend jetzt
auch tatsächlich freuen geht das so
weiter
erst mal schöne grüße aus dem cash
machine haben der versorgung also ich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass es
weitergeht mal mit den hausärzten haben
wir nicht nur 400 im zentrum wie bis
jetzt sondern 50.000 im center der
kollegin dr alex hat mich heute noch
unterstützt impfen
bei uns wir haben heute insgesamt in
dieser woche über 160 impfungen hier
durchziehen können sie können sich
vorstellen wenn wir genügend dem stoff
kriegen was für eine power haben aber
muss auch so sagen wir sind auch an der
grenze der belastbarkeit auch meine
mitarbeiter
aber dr alex ist auch jemand der auf der
intensivstation des krankenhauses
arbeitet und genau die situation kennt
und weiß wie dramatisch das da ist